the research on what creates outstanding
companies what really creates
outstanding organizations is
unequivocally clear that having a
philosophy of long term thinking is a
prerequisite for doing anything good
shows up in the data the research
madonnas is really good and i was like
well how can that be right that the very
thing that we know for sure is what's
needed to build great companies is
antithetical to the economic environment
that we're taking companies into you
know all of us Silicon Valley we're all
trying to build public companies we're
all trying to sell our companies to
public companies while trying to make
ourselves subject to these short-term
pressure which makes our companies less
valuable which means investors lose
money and it's like I thought we were I
thought it's a capitalist system and
that were for-profit companies so how
could this be right so did never made
sense to me and I finally was like aha
it just I was little in an airplane and
it came to me I said what we need is a
way for those companies which actually
are long-term and those investors that
are actually long-term to come together
for mutual benefit and we'll just build
our own market with our own social
contract that says we're gonna actually
run things for long term and we don't
need to be activists about it we don't
need to get only to run for president
anything just it's a for-profit company
these are all for profit companies well
we will actually make more money if
companies perform better which I did not
really expect to be controversial it
seemed like I thought I was making a QED
like straightforward deduction from the
first principles of like what is
capitalism to whatever I didn't even
know what a stock exchange was yet see I
told you all about a stock I didn't know
one thing about stock exchanges
I was just sitting I was literally
sitting there being like you know what I
need from first principles I need an
institution that can regulate the
behavior of investors and managers at
the same time so you invented a stock
exchange on that airplane yeah I was
like oh we should make a stock exchange
and I just wrote it in them just I was
sitting there with my could be with my
manuscript right here have it open I'll
just throw it in here and see what
happens why not i if you had told me
that day that this would be a
controversial idea to anybody I would
have been shocked and that was it that
was the idea and you know pretty easy
idea to say took three paragraphs in the
book to write it's not as easy of an
idea to build so I spent years just I
can't even describe this to you like
this is the first thing in my life where
I feel like I didn't my subjective
experiences I did not have the sight
my life was really good before I had
this idea I did I did not need this idea
honestly my experience with this idea
had me it came to me this I wrote it in
the thing and I was like good my work
here is done
I wrote it I'm an author now not an
entrepreneur I wrote it in the book I
did my responsibility I put it out into
the world and now this problem will
solve itself and I can go on with my
life and this is morning sex it would
not leave me alone will I keep me up at
night it would bother me all the time as
I would go around in the world and as
the book became a phenomenon and I got
to go work with companies I mean you
name an order of magnitude of companies
from two founders in a garage up to the
world's biggest multinationals and every
order magnet in between I've had the
chance to work with companies of that
size and I can now I can pretty much win
a bingo contest where you'd give me like
sector or industry of the company and
size and I'll be like oh yeah there's an
example oh yeah here's an example and
then you would cross that with corporate
function I can tell you a story about
people in that industry at that size and
that function how they were grappling
with with lean start so I got this
really wide education yet everywhere you
go this is the problem people complained
to you about you can't you can't avoid
it and once you've had this idea I just
like why is it such a bad idea I don't
understand and so I started to talk to
people about it and I I spent years just
asking everyone I knew you don't know
any investors know anybody that knows
anything about Wall Street
what is Wall Street how do you go there
is it a place is a thing what well is it
a state of mind what is it how do I
learn more about it and I asked VC's do
who you only public market people and
people I made the intros and I would
have these conversations big high on
this kid from Silicon Valley and I've
got this idea you tell me all the
reasons why it's terrible and they'd be
like no problem
first it violates the efficient market
hypothesis second
you know brokers will never go for it
third it's antisocial and it will lead
to communism fourth you name it I swear
to God I have a burden over the years
and what was so and I was just I was
like delighted I was like great one day
someone will sit me down and explain to
me why this is a bad idea and it will
leave me alone and the problem was
people's reasons for why it was a bad
idea it made no sense it wasn't that
like they were not persuasive because
they were almost all variations of like
kid I am making so much money from
things the way it is exactly right now
could you please go away and leave me
alone
people wouldn't say it exactly that way
but I started to learn I was like this
doesn't make sense nobody can answer the
question for me why like I was like I
have very simple questions why do we
report quarterly why are companies
allowed to give guidance I don't
understand meanwhile I'm working with
companies every day we're at the first
sign of trouble if the guidance is off
if the quarters not going well the very
first thing they do is cancel the
innovation projects you all if do this
you know what I'm talking about
we literally eat the seed corn as like a
best practice why so if you ask me why
do you do this it doesn't make and no
one could answer these questions it
wasn't like they had a really good
answer and that just was like I was like
I want to make it a little bit better
it's like me will be like I don't know
it's just how it is it's just gravity
right just this is just how it is
and so I started to ask people well how
do you build the new stock exchange I
had this idea for a new stock exchange
I'd like to build a new one and when you
I told you that look people get on your
face try this one it's like you're
saying I'd like to make a new moon and
it's like it's a weird question because
like hey we already have one it's fine
we don't need another one but also
that's not a human thing to do you don't
make a moon it's just it's in the sky
it's a thing and people have this image
the beautiful marble building with the
bull we're gonna have another bull it's
what what animal is your it's gonna
happen
I've heard all so eventually I got to a
moment where I met a securities lawyer
and the other problem is most people who
were experts in this topic make a lot of
money from the status quo so they won't
help you but I finally found someone
who's like at the perfect borderline of
just inside enough to know the answers
to my questions but not making so much
money that he was not invested in reform
and I said to him how do you make a new
Stock Exchange he said oh it's not that
hard
that one was like oh really is that you
just fill out form one and I did a
cartoon we did a double-take we're like
I'm sorry well I can't what he's like
yeah it's for it's called you need to
follow a form one application it's
literally form one and I was like I was
just I couldn't understand him he's like
listen you understand how government
forms are all numbered uh-huh this is
SEC form number zero zero one the
application to establish a national
securities exchange it's a freakin form
and I was just like you're kidding me
now it's like listen it's 200 pages long
and the most important thing about the
talking about I need to have a legal
memo written to explain why I wanted to
go talk to the SC about it's like when
you go to meet the SCC the most
important thing about your legal memo is
anyone want to guess I was like oh the
structure of my argument the precedent
that I can cite into whatever I'm very
earnest good student right it's like no
it's whose letterhead it will be lit and
written on what lawyer will write this
letter for you I was like who cares it's
on the American wages like kid listen
there's only three lawyers who are
really qualified for this it needs to be
on one of their letterhead and I'm like
oh man and then I said wait can I meet
these people I can meet it's like oh
sure yeah introduce you it was like all
these problems seemed like totally
intractable and then and this just has
been almost 10 years now of like one
foot in front of the other one step one
little experiment and so it's like yeah
you fill out the form it has a lot of
parts you have to hire a bunch of people
you have to raise a lot of money you
have to have the right lobbyists you
have to have the right lawyers you have
to learn all this jargon in this
impenetrable whatever to learn how
Washington DC actually works but okay it
was like each step didn't seem that hard
and I was like well I'll just take this
one step and see what happens and and I
was expecting for most of the first five
years of this that I would take a few
steps I would eventually meet the one
person that I finally meet the man
behind the curtain and kneed me like oh
kid you made it behind the curtain let
me now explain to you why this can never
work and it will leave you alone then I
should go back to my nuts like that
because turns would screw up gravity for
right it's like the problem with the
tides and people would die and act like
oh my god this thing